pensez à ce puissant souvenir
[Musique]
rendez-
le le plus heureux dont vous puissiez vous souvenir
on a l'impression qu'aucun temps ne s'est écoulé
et que beaucoup de temps s'est écoulé
je pense que c'est le moment idéal pour
s'asseoir avec tout le monde et se remémorer
la chose qui m'a le plus effrayé
était  l'implication que la chose la plus
significative de notre vie a été faite
et qu'il y a quelque chose de si curieux à
voir tout le monde
et être comme
s'il n'y en avait pas bien que l'
un des points forts de ma part ait été
quand j'ai dû faire semblant d'être hermione
prétendant être un meilleur truc je  je
n'aime pas attendre j'ai encore
les dents en fait je vais les mettre si
tu veux
ma soeur a des enfants qui ont eu
environ 10 11 12 ans et j'ai dit maths je ne sais pas
pour ce voldemort ce que tu
on te demande de jouer à voldemort
tu dois le faire
je ne serais pas la personne que je suis sans tant
de monde ici
c'est une chose très écrasante parce que
je t'ai vu monter et j'ai vu à
peu près toutes les étapes  de ma vie
quand les choses deviennent vraiment sombres et le temps  s
sont vraiment durs il y a quelque chose à propos de
Harry Potter qui rend la vie plus riche c'est
un lien fort que nous aurons toujours
[Musique]
nous sommes une famille et nous ferons toujours partie
de la vie de l'autre
[Musique]
toi